here is Mikey Anderson he'll be paired
with dowy again to start the season a
pass broken up Kopitar is there to clean
it up for dowy to by field to Kopitar high
slot feeds it right side by field shot pass
score anj kopar an early goal a minute 12
in [Music] he's on the left side he comes across
he's trying to defend the attack look at that he
just goes down so from that point on he
actually knocked his defense partner too
which prevented that partner teodor from
getting around to Kopitar you see teodor
he had to spin around so on a seemingly innocent
looking attack all of a sudden when one guy goes
down it becomes the bowling ball Everyone
Falls yeah eel recovering from that next
surgery about a year year and a half ago Jack
eel a Stanley Cup champion dubba in centers
[Music] score Matt Roy jumping up into the play
redirects the centering pass and both come off
the rush Matt Roy actually starts the plate
and he just keeps going he doesn't stop the
end result is a one-time shot quick release by
Matt but it's right in front of all the way and
it's the quickness of the release you see Hill
I don't think the goer expected it happening
Nick heg big defenseman 6 foot6 for Vegas to
another big frame on the blue line the veteran
petrangelo who gets it down into the Kings End
dowy takes a look his Outlet pass tip held in
shot tip and a score barbashev tipped home the
shot from between the circles behind the net dowy
looking for someone that's going to be open ends
up right there with petrangelo pinching down and
again how quickly it goes back towards net you
see where the tip is so we get the first power
play for the Kings who lead two to one fiala
at the goal line arson pass up high tipped Dy
Corrals it for fala in the middle Kopitar the
dowy to Kee a blast save rebound score Victor
arbiton
[Music] you can see with kempe shot of course
and this is an example that coaches will bring
back many times because shot rebound gets it
done copar Drew So Many Bodies to him and that
opened up the other guys and you'll take as
many of these as possible wide open that for
arson he has had a productive pre-season
arson out there on one of two power play
units Stone out for Vegas leaving for eel and
a cross for Stevenson who got bumped but he
dropped the puck and the Vegas golden knights
will set it up in the middle a chance eel say
rebound score Chandler Stevenson a power play
goal so the Kings have made a adjustments on
the peny kill there's probably going to be
more pressure up top you see gabov leaving
the front so sometimes that explosiones
you down low the concern for the Kings
not necessarily that rebound chance the kings
are probably going to allow more two-on ons
down low in tight spaces where they expected the
fenceman to make sure he's there to break up the
two-on-one very little time they take to put
it back to the front of the net you don't
allow the Kings to get back in position yep
exactly you don't want all that team that's
where the opening the opportunities are there
as we saw on the tip by bar garbish having a
slot there wasn't a king within 5 seven ft of
them bjornfot with it again pushes it towards
the [Applause] goenda barbashev to eel speeding
through Center hands it off tipped into the
middle Theodora backhander and he scores put
it in under the crossbar now the skill just
shows through here for Thor sometimes you can
tell the by the sound sometimes you can tell
by how it rebounds but that second wave attack
to watch the elevation of the puck we've talked
about Sydney Crosby in the pass with a back
hand wow right to the top right under the bar
gof showing some offensive flare fiala at the
left Circle looking for a shooting Lane feeds
Roy who dumps it down low and dubba Cycles
up high charges to the left circle to the
goal line high slot fala buries it dubba to
fiala we hope we hear that a lot during the
season and you'll see to watch him turn
the legs keeps going keeps going keeps
going keeps going keeps going look at
the legs and then yeah that's a great
read as dubis is going behind the net One
Way fella is mirroring in that movement
in front of that the other way that opens
up a lane quick release Kings with a onego
lead and he throws the puck back out
on the short side that's just a great
execution penalty boxes are empty as we start
the third period here at crypto.com Arena and
off the draw the golden knights will send it down
you have to find a way or you have to find a way
how can you get to top speed more because your
fast skater and you get to a game and you don't
use that speed coaches they have to find a way to
make you use it a chance play underway safe W on
the rebound scores so the golden knights tie it up
for the second time this afternoon Nick W makes it
44 but he would want this one because it's a a
shot that's high he thinks he has it obviously
he doesn't so the control of the rebound it's not
like he put it into a dangerous area but he lost
completely where the puck actually was and many
times with those big pads on you can't really feel
it but in that situation especially where the shot
came from look at that it's outside the circle you
mentioned the golden knights missing Riley Smith
from the Stanley Cup team they do have barbashev
now this year for the whole year so that makes a
little bit difference there too Mel to the net and
he scores oh nice hands Jack eel and the golden
Knights Midway through the third period have their
first lead of the game when you're beat wide in
this situation and how tight it becomes at the
end du ends up losing his stick 80 for the Kings
so he can't lean in front see he loses a stick now
that changes the entire Dynamic if dubuis has a
stick here and Gerald really on the replay didn't
look like a slash no it didn't look like much not
too strong no just enough to take a stick away one
timer and a score Mark Stone sets up his teammate
at the left Circle Maro and three unanswered goals
for Vegas here in the third they're up 6'4 and
to this the King St they were going to be able to
leave the zone and you can see how Trevor Moore's
backtracking to get back that's when marcheso
stops up look at Moore getting back marcheso says
I'm not going to drive anymore I'm going to get
my stick into the lane that shot is is absolutely
perfect on the onetime Philip Doo gives it a try
on left wing he'll send it down McNab behind his
own net hard around the wall knocked down by Moore
harson had it couldn't get it to Duba and now to
Center Ice eel at the empty net and he'll score
Jack eel with his fifth point of the game puts
a LD on this one 7 for Vegas breakdowns as far
as strategy and tactics the goal ending will be a
concern after today's game and Vegas just seems to
find that way I I talked about it earlier with
Bruce Gasson he saying we just wear down teams
sometimes so the Kings and golden knights will
say goodbye and then the wait until later on this
month when they meet here at crypto.com Arena for
the first of three times that game October 28th